How would you say I want to carry on?
Now you think "carry on,
I don't know this!"
So, one of the skills we want to really make use of these convertible words is to find the Latin equivalent
of carry on.
I want to carry on, I want to go on, I want to…? What is the Latin word that we could use here?
Nothing comes to mind?
Like?
So, think of-
Ah, continue.
So you can think of a -tion word that has something to do with carrying on?
Continuation.
Exactly,
good.
So, I want to continue:
Quiero continuar.
I want to continue it:
Quiero continuarlo.
Good.
I am trying to continue:
I've already forgotten what trying is.
So it's not about remembering, it's about knowing how to find it.
So there are a few things you could think about, that when we discuss this word, that could lead you back to it,
and the important thing is to
take that time to have those thoughts rather than just, "Oh, do I know it? Do I not?"
Intención.
There wasn't a rule here because it doesn't finish -ation.
Our rule was for ones that finish -ation, but it was very similar.
Do you remember what it is now?
I try,
so it ends in -o like-
Ah, intento.
good,
so that's I try.
We want to see first if we can find it...
relaxed, not... you know if your brain locks on "Do I remember it or don't I?" Game over. But if you go "Okay, what was that related to, what was that about?" And just see what pops up, then you are much more likely to get it. So, Intento. Intento is I try.
I try or I am trying to continue:
Intento continuar.
Good.
What is demostración?
Demonstration.
Did you notice something different though?
There's some change here.
Demostración?
There's no n.
Good.
Demostración.
So how would you say to demonstrate?
Demostrar.
Now if you get rid of that de-, how would it sound?
Mostrar.
Mostrar, and that means to show.
To show.
Mostrar.
So we might think again, mostrar has no connection that we can hook on to,
but usually when we have a look we can find some connection through English, Latin English, that helps us interiorize. Mostrar, to show.
The word for something is algo.
Algo.
A-l-g-o.
Algo,
good.
What was the word for you,
in I love you,
how was I love you?
Te quiero.
Te quiero,
so it was te.
So how would you say, I want to show you something,
in this order,
I want to show you something:
Quiero mostrarte algo.
I want to show you something.
What again was I go or I am going and it was related to voyage we said.
Voy.
The beginning bit of voyage,
and you're mostly going to hear it pronounced more like a soft b.
Voy.
Now, just as in English,
we say I am going to... and we talk about the future.
I am going to continue.
I am going to eat later.
We can do exactly the same thing in Spanish.
The only difference is that even though, for example, if we use continue – continuar - continuar means to continue.
In Spanish we say voy a continuar.
It's actually because voy is a verb of movement,
when we are putting a "to" form,
a verb that is "to" something like continuar after a verb of movement, a verb that has some kind of motion in its meaning like voy: I am going,
Spanish wants to show this feeling of motion
so you say I am going to and you put the to for that movement, even if you're not actually moving and you're just using it to speak about the future.
So, if you want to say, for example, I am going to confiscate it. I am going to confiscate it:
Voy a confiscarlo. Good.
Voy a confiscarlo.
Very good.
How do you say I am going to examine it?
I am going to examine it:
Good.
Voy a examinarlo.
Now we said lo is it or him.
Now the plural of him is them.
This is not very obvious in English because him and them, they look very different as words.
We don't ever think of them as the plural of him or of her but it is.
It's very obvious in Spanish,
lo means him or it and if you want to get them, if you want to make it plural, what do you think you might do?
Just add the s?
Los.
Good.
So now we have the word for them.
To see is ver,
We have view in English, like view, ver.
So how would you say, I want to see them?
Quiero a verlos?
Why a here?
Quiero verlos.
So, ver is to see.
If you say I am going to see them, how is it going to be?
Voy a verlos.
Good.
But if you say, I want to see them? Quiero verlos.
And if you say I am trying to see them?
Intento verlos.
Good.
No a.
Intento verlos.
Because ver is to see.
To try, so trying in its "to" form,
to try is intentar.
Intentar.
This is to try.
So how would you say I want to try?
Quiero intentar.
Good.
I am going to try:
Voy a intentar.
Good. With a. Voy a intentar.
I am going to try to see them?
I am going to try to see them:
Voy a intentar a verlos.
No,
verlos.
Voy intentar-
Slower.
Voy a intentar verlos.
Good.
Let me give you another example of a verb that connects with this a,
so voy isn't isolated,
we can understand the concept better if we see another verb of movement.
So another verb of movement is pasar.
What do you think pasar means?
Is it to pass?
Yes, pasar is to pass and to pass by,
so I'm going to pass by to visit you.
I'm going to pass by to visit you.
How would we say this?
The first bit is I am going.
Voy.
Good.
I am going to pass by:
A pasar.
Good.
To visit you:
Visitarlo,
visitarte.
Well actually lo, other than him and it, can also mean formal you,
so if you're speaking formally, you can use this lo as well.
But I want to go back to pasar.
Pasar is a verb of movement.
Let's take the sentence again from the beginning.
The whole sentence is I'm going to pass by to visit you.
Voy a. So it's voy a pasar a visitarlo.
Good,
lo if you are speaking formally or te if you are speaking informally.
Voy a pasar a visitarte.
Which would mean him, it or you (formal).
How would you say formal, by the way, in Spanish?
Formal.
And formally:
Formalmente.
Very good.
Now, if you want to say, I am going to try to pass by to visit you
we have to think which ones we are going to use this a with and which ones not, which is a great exercise for us to internalise this rule.
So, I am going to try:
Voy a intentar.
To pass by:
A, no. Voy a intentar pasar.
To visit you:
A visitarte.
Very good.
So we learned that rule.
Voy a intentar pasar a visitarte.
There's not many times that we have something between the verbs
so there's not going to be a lot of rules like this, don't worry,
but this one's important because there are many important verbs of motion that we will be putting this a after.
How was to demonstrate again?
Demonstrar.
And what happened to that n?
Demostrar.
And what is to show?
You get rid of- Mostrar. Good. Mostrar. And the word for something I mentioned was algo,
algo.
Something.
I want to show you something.
Let's speak informally.
So we're going to use te.
Good.
I want to show you something.
Quiero mostrarte algo.
So maybe you call somebody and you say where are you?
I'm at home.
Okay, I want to pass by.
to show you something:
I want to pass by to show you something.
Quiero pasar a - what was it? To show you something.
Mostrarte algo.
Good.
Quiero pasar a, because we had the verb of movement,
mostrarte algo.
So if we are connecting a verb of movement to another verb
we connect using this extra a, to. Quiero pasar a mostrarte algo. Good.